vous dites Lio c'est pas moi je la mets
en scène tous les jours elle n'existe
pas Lio euh j'ai fait un seul coup à Lio
j'ai vieilli
faire une interview maintenant on va
baisser la lumière ah ça y est on ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
c'est ma joie
aussi tiens je vais vous mettre
pas il m'ouvrini pourquoi
la chanson
mon prof de gym quand je fais mon sport
il met ça faire des abdos sinon je le
fais pas
vous avez dit vous avez déclaré c'est
bizarre j'ai toujours été une femme
seule j'étais accompagnée finalement
très peu de temps et j'ai eu mes enfants
avec des hommes différents
ma célébrité finalement est un énorme
problème dans ma vie sentimentale est-ce
que vous pensez vraiment que si vous
n'aviez été si vous n'aviez pas été lié
si vous étiez resté Vanda est-ce que
vous auriez moins de problèmes avec les
hommes
oui pourquoi
parce que c'est très difficile de se
retrouver à un moment donné
comme étant monsieur Lio et moi je l'ai
entendu ça des gens qui venaient qui
présentaient mes hommes comme Monsieur
Lio et en fait moi je trouvais c'était
ridicule de la part des autres mais eux
petit à petit trouver ridicule de ma
part d'être Lio mais c'était dommage
parce que je l'étais avant je ne pouvais
pas arrêté tout d'un coup c'était
maintenant c'est comme une seconde
nature Lio et ça a posé des problèmes
oui ça pose des problèmes je vous ai
posé problème de gagner plus que son
homme aussi alors c'est vrai alors donc
voilà moi j'ai fait le compte quand même
là
on trouve normal par contre de dire
tout le monde s'en fout hein
c'est suffisamment chamailler sur des
plateaux pour que je puisse vous faire
un compliment sincère je vous trouve
très belle en ce moment là la
présentement vous avez un site très joli
vous êtes une belle robe vous êtes des
belles nattes et j'adore les brunes et
vous avez du rouge lèvres un peu rouge
ça ça me plaît ça alors Béatrice je te
le dis tu pouvais mettre le même genre
de rouge à lèvres que lui ça me ferait
plaisir voilà bon allez maintenant
une portugaise ça le fait à Renaud hein
le Portugal
alors
j'ai compté les hommes
c'est évidemment c'est pas encore Gloria
Lasso mais quand même c'est sur la route
c'est-à-dire il y a eu d'abord votre
premier
Duvalier qu'on adore tous hein voilà
vous êtes 13 ans et demi
ensuite il y a eu Esteban notre ami
Esteban qui vous avec qui vous avez vu
Nubia
ensuite il y a eu Patrick Alexis avec
qui vous avez deux enfants Igor et
Smeralda donc là on est déjà un deux
trois
non attendez 1
2 3 4 ZAD le dernier en date celui avec
qui vous avez les jumelles voilà
cinq enfants
sur les plateaux il y a au bain douche
alors vous avez déclaré mon ami Hugo
Pratt m'avait pourtant conseillé de ne
pas tuer le désir dans ce milieu à vide
de chair fraise personne ne veut d'une
fille avec 5 gosses au basque vous
pensez que ça vous en dit cap
aujourd'hui tous ces enfants moi ça
m'handicapé
moi ça m'handicap pas au contraire dans
ma vie de femme c'est quelque chose de
génial mais ça ça handicap dans mon
travail mais oui bien sûr ça m'handicap
dans mon travail parce que c'est pas de
trouver des gens en général les femmes
veulent bien travailler avec moi mais
derrière une femme réalisatrice il y a
toujours un homme producteur et l'homme
producteur lui n'a pas envie d'une
artiste à problèmes entre guillemets
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui pourrait
éventuellement lui refuser de lui donner
la 2 centièmes heure supplémentaire
gratos puisque c'est maintenant ce qu'on
vous demande moi depuis que j'ai
commencé à tourner
mais cachés ont été divisés par trois
voire 4 toujours soit disant pour des
problèmes de cinéma français qui ne
marchent pas mais j'ai toujours vu les
les producteurs avec la même BMW et les
mêmes costumes chez routine donc donc si
vous voulez je trouve que c'est comme un
nouvel esclavagisme parce que comme on
manque de boulot c'est difficile pour
tout le monde donc on commence à dire
aux techniciens faut diviser vos prix et
puis si c'est pas vous qui faites pas
voilà et donc ça c'est effectivement et
donc il y a autre chose qui joue c'est
quand tout d'un coup des producteurs ont
le choix entre Lio et une autre et une
autre brune pas trop grosse ils vont
prendre peut-être l'autre brune jolie
mais qui a pas 5 enfants et moi je vais
être éliminé sur ce critère
immédiatement
oui mais c'est la vérité je veux pas
pourquoi
dites-moi où est mon tous les cas pour
une fille qui a eu 5 enfants vous êtes
vachement bien
et pour une fille qui n'a pas je vais
commencer
vous
vous dites là vous avez des problèmes
avec votre jus actuel et pourtant vous
disiez je crois que j'ai trouvé ce que
je cherchais je suis une butineuse il me
faut un vrai appel pour m'arrêter avec
lui il y a eu une vraie osmose comment
ça se fait que ça soit terminé aussi mal
après cette vraie osmose
à me poser qui me pose et des sacrés
problèmes je ne sais pas
non vous aviez l'air d'être tellement en
avoir enfin trouvé je suis très
amoureuse de lui toujours oui mais je ne
veux plus jamais vivre avec lui c'est
différent vous allez vous revoir quand
même
pas là pour dire ça donc lui il a quand
même pris deux mois ferme
par vengeance je vais quand même un peu
porter plainte sinon on n'a pas pris
deux mois ferme
parce que quand on porte plainte c'est
qu'on n'a pas d'autre solution quand on
essaie de régler des problèmes
comme on peut avec ses moyens mais que
un moment donné on va d'échec en échec
et de violence en violence et bien on
s'en refaire à la justice c'est pas que
je trouve ça formidable mais c'est que
je n'avais pas d'autres solutions la
justice représente le père c'est c'est
une autorité à laquelle on s'en remet
quand on reconnaît notre échelle notre
échec à nous de résoudre le problème
voilà vous avez dit vous jugez la
sanction un peu sévère les six mois les
6 mois de prison
je ne suis pas a priori pour la prison
parce que je trouve que c'était pas là
qu'on résout les problèmes mais
les deux mois fermes n'étaient qu'une
partie de la sentence et moi j'avais
besoin de protection et je l'ai obtenu
et la justice a fait des grands pas pour
les femmes battues il fallait qu'elle
les fasse parce qu'on est vraiment seul
dans ces cas-là et surtout vous êtes
toujours coupable moi la plupart des
hommes qui m'ont parlé depuis n'ont pas
du tout le sentiment de s'adresser à une
victime mais c'est comme les femmes
victimes c'est que je l'ai bien cherché
comme en plus tout le monde sait que
chez un sale caractère on se dit que
vraiment j'ai du torturer ce pauvre
homme mais c'est quand même moi qui
avait le nez cassé et une entorse
cervicale et quatre vertèbres déplacée
qu'on a dû remettre le les Folies
Bergères et que ça a été terrible et que
je m'en remets toujours pas moi en tout
cas sur scène ça se voit pas et sur
scène ça se voit pas mais ça c'est la
magie du spectacle je suis heureuse sur
scène alors vous flippez un peu sur
votre âge ce que quand on vous voit on a
du mal à comprendre franchement vous
dites Lio c'est pas moi je la mets en
scène tous les jours elle n'existe pas à
Lio j'ai fait un seul coup à Lio j'ai
vieilli non mais ça je le disais il y a
10 ans déjà de ça parce que c'est vrai
Lio était la représentation de
l'adolescence elle avait entre 12 et 14
ans quand je l'ai choisi c'était mon âge
à l'époque dans une BD de Jean-Claude
Forest et elle était le symbole de
l'adolescente oui et c'est vrai que je
ne suis plus le symbole de l'adolescente
avec cinq enfants
c'est au Ghana oui est-ce que est-ce que
vous
je ne critique pas le Gana je tiens à le
dire je veux pas d'histoire je ne
critique pas le Ghana est-ce que vous
avez vous dites j'ai du mal à me voir
vieillir j'ai la mécanique ça faiblice
n'est jamais très agréable oui c'est
vrai et c'est jamais très agréable de
voir les
regards des hommes toujours attirés par
la jeunesse mais moi vous êtes très
attirante vous êtes une femme dans la
plénitude là oui non mais faut pas
flipper
très jeune avec un personnage de Lolita
effectivement Banana Split et tout ça
mais quand on vous voit là
je crois une chose je crois que on se
voit énormément dans le regard que
l'homme que vous aimez porte sur vous et
je crois que quand le regard qu'on
reçoit quelque chose qui
qui vous affaiblit qui qui vous
remettait tellement en question et sur
des choses qui sans doute sont ridicules
moi je trouve que c'est une perte
d'énergie totale mais la vérité et que
ça moi ça me marque il y a des choses
qui m'ont marqué c'est vrai que je me
regarde plus dans la glace avec la même
le même la même désinvolture disant
parce que moi je ne me suis jamais
regardé dans la glace avec attention
j'étais désinvolte et je la perds
et c'est une peur qui vient alors je
m'en détourne très vite mais je crois
que je crois que c'est ça tout
simplement je crois qu'on ne vieillit
jamais quand les gens nous aiment et
vous donnent quelque chose
que vous problème c'est que dans la tête
on vit pas vraiment mais le corps
vieillit et puis après les gens n'y
croient pas quand elle leur dit ça alors
vous dites quand même j'ai hâte d'être
une vieille dame indigne
jamais aimé avoir le cul entre deux
chaises
on y va c'est vrai qu'on a envie à un
moment de se dire il y a un moment on se
dit la vieillesse il faut que ça serve à
ne plus rien avoir la de rien
au moins cet avantage là c'est ça et de
pouvoir faire plein de conneries et puis
personne n'ose venir vous dire quelle
conne ça c'est génial ça c'est un moment
que j'attends avec la peinture merci
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu